اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى لقاء خاص مع عضو
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي عن ولايه كارولينا
الجنوبيه السيناتور
نرحب بوجودك معنا سنه دعنا نبدا بالحديث
عن اسباب زيارتك الحاليه الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه فقد كنتم في جده وقابلتم
سمو ولي العهد محمد بن سلمان لبضعه اسباب
لقد اشترت المملكه الطائرات بوينج من طراز
787 دريم لاينر بقيمه 37 مليار دولار
امريكي تم تصنيعها في صوت كارو فرقه رائعه
للولايه
نعم شراء منتجات بقيمه 37 مليار دولار تم
التصنيعها في ولايه ولابد لي ان احضر
واعرب عن شكري فانتم بصدد اطلاق خطوط
طيران جديده طيران الرياض وسوف تستخدمون
طائرات بوينكس 787 وهذه الصفقه شراء كبيره
ونثمن هذا الامر كثيرا ثانيا نعيش في
اوقات محفوفه بالمخاطر والامور تتغير في
المنطقه باتجاهين اتجاه نحو الافضل واخر
نحو الاسوا السعوديه في وضع افضل بكثير من
مناطق اخرى سيئه لذا لابد لان اتي لاقول
فلنجعل المملكه افضل لكن زياره كانت مثيره
للغايه وحظيت بترحيب كبير وحفاوه في
الاستقبال فلنرى ما الذي ستحمله لنا
الايام في جعبتها في المستقبل
سوف نعرج على هذا الامر ونتحدث عن ايران
والصين بعد قليل لكنني اود ان اتحدث عن
هذا النشاط المحموم الذي نراه من جانب
الولايات المتحده اذا السعوديه فقد سمعنا
عن اتصال لجيك سالفن وزياره التي التقى
فيها مع ولي العهد وها انتم هنا اليوم في
اي اطار تضعون هذا النشاط المستمر من جانب
الولايات المتحده تجاه السعوديه
الفرص والحيطه الحيطه اننا هنا اليوم من
اجل اغتنام الفرص فقد تكون هذه افضل فرصه
اراها منذ عقود من لتطوير العلاقات بيننا
عبر ولي العهد عن رغبته بالتحقيق اربعه
اشياء مع الولايات المتحده فهو يرغب بان
يكون لديكم برنامج خاص بكم للطاقه النوويه
من اجل الاغراض السلميه واعتقد ان هذا امر
ممكن وساحاول ان اساعد بهذا الخصوص
وباشراك شركات امريكيه متخصصه في مجال
الطاقه النوويه للحضور من اجل مساعده
السعوديه في الحصول على برنامج للطاقه
النوويه لكنني احسب انها مساله يمكن حلها
ومن ضمن الاشياء التي يرغب ولي العهد
بالحصول عليها برنامج طاقه نووي لاغراض
سلميه في السعوديه عكس ايران بمناسبه
الحديث عن برنامج ايران النووي الى اين
تتجه الامور فقد راينا عده جولات من
المحادثات في فيينا في مسعى لاحياء
الاتفاق تتجه نحو الاسوا اعتقد انهم
يرغبون بالحصول على برنامج الاسلحه
النوويه وليس برنامج للطاقه النوويه
السعوديه ترغب بالحصول على برنامج للطاقه
النوويه من اجل تنويع مصادر الطاقه الخاصه
بها وتحديث اقتصادها يوجد اليورينيوم
بوفره في السعوديه ويمكن استخراجه
واستخدامه ليس لاغراض محليه فحسب بل من
اجل المساعده في الحصول على برنامج سلمى
للطاقه النوويه اما ايران فهي تحاول الصنع
قنبله نوويه ولديها نظام ديني
واجندتهم تجاه العالم تطهير الاسلام وفقا
لصورتهم الخاصه وتدمير دوله اسرائيل وشن
هجوم عليها يمكن القول بان الاتفاق النووي
مع ايران اصبح ميته
اذا يمكن القول انه اصبح ميتا تحت حكم
اداره الرئيس بايدن لكنني ارى انه يوجد في
الصواب لا يوجد لدي اعتراض على امتلاك
ايران للطاقه النوويه لكنني لا اوافق على
التخصيب لانها اكبر دوله راعيه للارهاب
بموجب القانون الامريكي يرى
وبمجرد وصولها الى 90% سوف تمتلك قنبله
نوويه لكن اسرائيل لن تسمح بحدوث ذلك لذا
اود ان اتي الى هنا لاخبر اصدقائنا في
السعوديه بان ما ترونه في برنامج ايران
النووي امر مؤرق بنسبه لكم فهو تهديد
وجودي لدوله اسرائيل لذا فالاشياء الاربعه
التي يرغب ولي العهد بالتحقيقها هي برنامج
سلمى للطاقه النوويه ويرغب بابرام اتفاقيه
تجاره حره مع الولايات المتحده كما ان
رؤيه 2030 ستفتح الباب على مصراعيه
للاستثمار المباشر في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وعلى الصعيد الدفاعي مع الولايات
المتحده الشيء الاساسي الذي يرغب تحقيقه
هو ان تكون علاقه قائمه على الصفقات فهو
يحاول ان يبني علاقه اشبه بعلاقه اليابان
واستراليا مع حلف النيتو ولا اعلم اذا
سنبرم اتفاقيه دفاع مشترك مع السعوديه
ماذا عن الولايات المتحده ماذا تريد من
السعوديه
ما اريده على الصعيد العسكري هو علاقه يتم
بموجبها بيع اسلحه امريكيه الى السعوديه
لمساعدتها في مواجهه اعدائنا المشترك واود
استمرار تدريب ضباطكم في كلياتنا العسكريه
وابرام بعض الاتفاقيات مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وسوف اؤيد اتفاقيه الدفاع
المشترك لكني لست متاكدا اذا ما كنا سنحصل
على القدر الكافي من التصويت لها لكن
المهم اتفاقيه تجعل من السعوديه اشباه
بدوله من حلف النيتو وليس من خصومه بناء
على ما ذكرته فلنتحدث عن الوجود الامريكي
في السعوديه يرى البعض انه تقلص في
السنوات القليله الماضيه وانا اتحدث من
الناحيه السياسيه بكل تاكيد كيف تنظرون
الى الوجود الامريكي في المنطقه
اعتقد انه اخذ في التزايد اولا ابلغت ولي
العهد والقيادات السعوديه باننا لسنا
راحلين امريكا لن تغادر شمال شرق سوريا
عندما انسحبنا من بغداد في عهد الرئيس
اوباما قلت هذا خطا ولا يمكن فعل ذلك فهم
غير مستعدين هناك بعد وسرعان ما اصبح داعش
الخطر الداهم بعد ان عاد بوحشيه ودمر
الطائفه اليزيديه وقتل الالاف من الاشخاص
في المنطقه وفي الخارج كان العراق منطلقا
لما سموه الخلافه واستخدم لشن هجمات على
الولايات المتحده وفرنسا ودول اخرى الجنود
الامريكيون 900 في شمال شرق سوريا الذين
يعملون مع قوه سوريا الديمقراطيه يشكلون
مصدا لاي هجمات اخرى من داعش ضد امريكا
فانا لا اثق بتركيا ولا اثق بالاسد ولا
اثق بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه للدفاع عن
بلادي فمن غير الانصاف ان اطلب القيام
بذلك وما اود تحقيقه مع شعوب المنطقه
الشراكه تركيا دوله عضو في حلف النيتو
لكنك قلت للتو بانك لا تثق بالحلفاء
للدفاع عن بلدكم
باحد البطه للدفاع عن الولايات المتحده
دون وجودنا بركي ضد الاسلام المتطرف نقطه
انتهى ان سحبنا من افغانستان وسوف نعاني
من تداعيات ذلك تحدث الرئيس ترامب عندما
كان في صده الحكم عن سحب الوجود الامريكي
من افغانستان وبمجرد انسحابنا صرع
الطالبان لحكم البلاد هناك النساء اللواتي
كنت اقابلهن خلال السنوات العشرين الماضيه
نذكرندي بالنساء اللواتي قابلتهن هنا خلال
الايام الثلاثه الماضيه فقد قابلت اكثر
نساء جمالا وموهبه على وجه الارض واخريات
عملنا في الفنون ويحملن نظره متفائله لكن
لهؤلاء النساء نظريات ايضا في افغانستان
ويمكنني ان اتخيل ما الذي يشعرن به اليوم
انت صوتت لمصلحه ترامب فلنتحدث قليلا عنه
وعن تلك المحاكمات والازمات التي يواجهها
هل تعتقدون انه له الفرصه في الفوز
بالانتخابات ام ان المحاكمه سوف تضعف من
فرص نجاحه في الرئاسه
في منهات تحمل دوافع سياسيه فهو الشخص
الاول الذي تتم مقاضاته في تاريخ مدينه
نيويورك بموجب تلك النظريه القانونيه فقد
نظروا في جنح القانونيه سقطت بحكم التقاضي
وطرحوها مجددا من خلال نظريه قانونيه
جديده لمقاضاته كل قليله ان وجدت تنظر الى
هذه المحاكمه انها قانونيه ولا يعتقدون ان
اي مواطن اخر كان ليقاض بهذه الطريقه
باستثناء ترامب لكنه في الفتره الحاليه هو
الاوفر حظها وما زال الحزب الجمهوري يتذكر
عهد ترامب جيدا فقد نج في تحصين الحدود
بشده والاكتفاء الذاتي في مجال الطاقه
ورسم سياسه خارجيه قويه اعتقد ان ترامب في
وضع جيد ما يؤهله للفوز بالترشح اما عند
الانتخابات العامه فسوف تكون النتائج
متقاربه للغايه انا هنا اليوم للحديث عن
تطوير علاقاتنا ليس من منطلق الحزب الواحد
من المناسب تماما لو استطعنا ان نبدا فصل
جديدا من العلاقات الطبيعيه وتطويرها ايضا
في عهد الرئيس بايدن لقد تحدثت الى الرئيس
وجيك
وجميعنا نحاول تلبيه طلب ولي العهد بافضل
طريقه ممكن
قائلا انك تريد محاوله الارتقاء بالعلاقه
مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه الى المستوى
التالي فما هو المستوى التالي
يتمثل المستوى التالي في جعل المملكه
العربيه السعوديه شريكا اكثر استراتيجيا
لكن الم تكن العلاقه استراتيجيه على
الدوام بين حسنا لاكون صريحا معك فقد كانت
علاقه قائمه على المصالح المتبادله لم اكن
انوي الحضور هنا مجددا لماذا انا هنا لان
الرؤيه 2030 حقيقه ملموسه ماذا كانوا
يطلقون عليها
لذا اريد ان يفوتني شيء انا الاخر اذا هذه
هي الصفقه هنا في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اليس كذلك لا اريد لامريكا ان
تفوت ما اعتقد انه تغيير جذري نحو الافضل
كانت لدينا علاقه سيئه للغايه ولا سيما
اعقاب احداث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر وحادثه
خاشقجي ومشاكل معقده للغايه لكنك هنا
وشاهدت الاصلاحات الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
تحتك نفس سمولي العهد محمد بن سلمان فكيف
تنظر الى ذلك اصلاحات ايجابيه للغايه لذا
ما اريد فعله وانا اقترح ان النساء
اللواتي التقيت بهن واللواتي يتحدثن عن
المملكه العربيه السعوديه من حيث تمكنهن
من الخروج دون محرم من الرجال وقياده
السيارات واداره اعمالهن الخاصه فضلا عن
ان نسبه
37% والعمل حاليا هي من النساء اريد منهن
العوده الى الولايات المتحده وساقيم
مادوبه عشاء ودعيني هنا اذكر السفيره ريما
المتميزه وساضع زملائي يسمعون قصصهم واريد
لبلدي ان يكون جزءا مما اعتقد انه التغيير
الجذري الاكبر في تاريخ الشرق الاوسط
المعاصر
بالعوده الى عام 2018 ذكرت انك لن تتواجد
هنا مره اخرى حيث كانت لديك مشاعر وموقف
صارم حيال التواجد هنا مره اخرى لكن حل
عام 20 23 وها انت اليوم هنا فهل يتعلق
الامر برمته بمساله عدم رغبتك في تفويت اي
شيء
تتعلق المساله بالتغيير الذي يشهده العالم
وقد سلكت المملكه العربيه السعوديه مسارا
جديدا لاصدقك القول لا يزال عام 2018 يلقي
بظلاله على المشهد لكن ثمه اشياء تحصل لم
اكن اؤمن بامكانيه حصولها واعتقدت انها
مجرد اقاويل كذلك شئت لارى بام عيني
وساعود الى الوطن واخبر الزملائي اذا كان
بالامكان تحقيق رؤيه 2030 فمن شان ذلك جعل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه مركز استقطاب
سياحي وشريكا تجاريا افضل واعتقد انه اذا
كان بالامكان استغلال هذه الفرصه للانحراف
في تحالف استراتيجي مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه عسكريا واقتصاديا فاعتقد ان ذلك
يستحق من القدوم الى هنا وان اكون جزءا من
ذلك لذلك وبصفه سيناتور امريكيا لدي الحق
في تغيير مساره غيرت المملكه العربيه
السعوديه مسارها ولا يعني ذلك انه ليس ثمه
اي مشاكل اتفهم التعامل مع الصين لحد ما
هو مع ايران الى حد ما لكن اليك ما اخبرت
به قياده بلدك اي اتفاقيه مع الاسد من
شانها تهديد الوجود الامريكي في شمال شرق
سوريا ستلقى معارضه لدينا 2500 جندي في
بغداد يحاول الايرانيون طردين من المنطقه
ولا يريدون وجودنا هنا لاننا نقف حجر عصر
امام التحقيق اهدافهم على المدى البعيد
بما انك عرجت على ذلك هل ترمي كل هذه
الزيارات والاتصالات والمبادرات تجاه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الى تعزيز
تواجدكم وانكم ما زلتم هنا وتريدون البقاء
وانكم اصدقاء احاول ان افهم وجهه علاقتكم
مع الصين وايران وانا هنا لاقول انني
منبهر للغايه من التطورات التي شهدتها
وانه ثمه فرصه سانحه للذهاب بعلاقتنا الى
المستوى التالي لكن الصين حاولت استبدال
اليوان الصيني بالدولار وهو ما سيكون
بمثابه ضربه مؤلمه للولايات المتحده انا
هنا لاقول ان الولايات المتحده ستدافع عن
الدولار قلت انني اريد ان اكون احدا
النواب الذين بوسعهم سرد قصه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الجديده حيث ارغب ان
اعود في الخريف رفقه المزيد من الاشخاص
بصحبته وامنوا تعزيز الروابط التجاريه
بيننا وابرام اتفاقيه تجاره حره والانخراط
في علاقه دفاعيه استراتيجيه لكن في
المقابل انا هنا لاقول انه لدينا مصالحنا
ايضا بالنسبه لايران والصين تنظر الولايات
المتحده للبلدين على انهما خصمان لها
نشا كوفيد من الصين لكنهما كذب حيال
المساله
ودمرت اقتصادا سعاده السيناتور ما رايك
بجميع الزيارات الاوروبيه التي شهدناها
مؤخرا الى الصين فقد شاهدنا زياره لاولاف
شيلت ماكغون ورئيس وزراء اسبانيا الى
الصين مؤخرا فماذا تشعر حيال ذلك
في زياره الصين ليس لدي مانع من زياره
الصين لكن ما الذي عساك تقوله عندما تذهب
الى هناك كانت زياره ماكرون عباره عن محض
كارثه تايوان لا اريد الخوض في السياسه
الصينيه لكنها تعد ديمقراطيه عكفنا على
دعمها في الولايات المتحده لعقود وفي حال
شده الصين هجوما عسكريا لم نجلس نكتب في
الايدي ونحن نشاهد تايوان تدمر اذا هل كان
هذا هو محور الزياره الاساسيه تايوان
بالاهتمام خرج مصرحا بالقول لا اعتقد ان
تايوان هي تلك المشكله الكبيره لديه
تصريحات مثيره للجدل حول الولايات المتحده
كذلك
حسنا لدينا حلفاء فرنسيون جيدون لكن اعتقد
ان مقاله يشجع الصين غازت روسيا اوكرانيا
هذه فسيكون الدور التالي على تايوان
وفي حال نقوصنا عن دعم الاوكرانيين الذين
يستبصرون لنجاح حريتهم فمن المرجح ان تغزو
الصين تايوان حينها سترى ايران ان الغرب
لا يجيد سوى الثرثره
هل هناك اي حل سلمي للحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه فقد شهدنا في الوثائق المسربه
مؤخرا عدم ورود اي ذكر للحل السلمي ثم تحل
سلمي على روسيا الانسحاب تحت وطاه السلاح
والاستبصال في الدفاع يتعين على روسيا
مغادره اوكرانيا اعتقد انه عام
1994 سلمت اوكرانيا 1700 قطعه السلاح
النووي الى روسيا بعد انهيار الاتحاد
السوفياتي وتوقع اتفاق بين روسيا
وبريطانيا واوكرانيا بما يضمن سيادتها بما
في ذلك شبه جزيره القرم لكن بوتين مزقت
تلك الوثيقه وارتكب جرائم حرب على نطاق
مروع وعبث بنظام العالمي ويتعين عليه دفع
الثمن غاليه علينا مقارنه الظلم ما الذي
يتعيد علينا القيام به ليس عليك احتلال
ارض الجوار وانما عليك تطوير المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وترقيه اقتصادك والمضي
قدما في تحديث المنظور الديني وهذا هو
المسار الذي ارغب برؤيته وليس مسار بوتين
رائع للاسف يداهمنا الوقت
استمتعت بالحوار معك وارغب بالاستمرار
اكثر لكن وقتنا ضيق للاسف شكرا على وقتك
سيد غرام ويسعدنا وجودك في السعوديه
مع لقاء خاص مع السيناتور الجمهوري في
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي السنتر الانستغرام
شكرا لطيب متابعه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات